Okay so now let's run this code to see what the
output looks like. Okay, so all this does is print out
a complete listing of all the airport codes and above this,
all of the carrier codes. Now it's these values then, that we're
going to use in order to mine the data we need
from this particular data source. So if we're going to do that,
we need to have a good understanding of exactly how requests
need to be formulated to this website. Okay, let's take a closer
look then. If we scroll up a little bit,
we can see the form that's used to submit
any requests based on these selectors and the submit
button. Now any time you are doing a scraping task
like this, you absolutely have to understand exactly how
the site expects requests. Some sites are pickier than others.
Some sites have more security procedures built in or
more constraints that you're going to have to deal with.
So our first step is figuring out what URL
we have to access, and what HTTP method we
need to use. So the HTTP method is post and the URL we need to access is this
data elements, ASPX URL, passing it to parameter data
equals 2. Now, it turns out that that is
exactly this URL here. So submitting this particular form
simply executes a request against exactly the same URL.